the gyro can experience it you know
people don't realize when they lived
there but when you when you're in a
place with giant cement buildings you
know that they're tall you're in
fight-or-flight the whole time because
they're big yeah because you're you're
threatened by these big masses that
could fall over and yeah absolutely
and you intuitively you're living in
that and then the noise and all of the
all the people because I you know I grew
up sitting in the back of the class
right I go to restaurant I find a chair
against the wall like I I go look for a
chair and go where's you know I'll sit
in the corner I want to see what's
coming I like to see what's coming so
and you go you know you go to New York
and there's just you're bombarded from
every single angle right and so you're
in fight or flight you're just you're
constantly on guard to you know you
don't know what's gonna you know I'll
take my chances in the ocean yeah I love
visiting yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah as far
as living there man I just don't and my
friend Jeff lives there and he's like
the energy of the city who talks about
the energy it's amazing I'm like okay
well it's retail therapy deal yeah
retail therapy some retail Mecca it's
why every woman in the world moves there
you know they want to show up shop and
then your friend goes there's a lot of
energy here is all the people people are
yeah and they're doing things it makes
me want to do things yeah yeah but I
want to do things anyway I don't need
that yeah yeah well we weren't meant to
live stacked on top of each other that's
not in our nature that's not in our
biology now these are an abundance of
everything yeah there's a lot of things
that make it attractive right
it's editors editor I mean there's
beautiful women that make it attractive
there's no blue all the food you ever
wanted to make that attractive you know
there's all there's an abundance of
stuff and there's always something you
do you go to the theater you don't have
to be self-motivated you don't be self
driven right you just there's always
three you know ten parties and a bunch
of things and speakers and cyah and just
anything you can think of there's every
aspect of it right so I think that's has
an attractiveness about it but Minh our
essence do we belong in these these
metropolis mmm they don't really have
any in nature there was
we wouldn't actually that wouldn't be a
place that you know and we can only
handle so many people at once anyway
like we can only have real intimate
relationships with like a hundred and
Gatineau 130 people or something
something crazy yeah that's like 150
yeah yeah yeah I'm what I'm fascinated
by though is that these things exist
everywhere and that cities exists in
almost every single country there's a
place like a Manhattan or like in LA
where everybody's just jammed in
together like what is it about people
that makes us want to live like this
that's an interesting thing that's an
interesting question why are we
attracted to that to that
well the abundance you know that we're
all and we were drawn to go where
everybody wants to go a little bit like
sheep you know like we all go where
everybody wants to go opportunity I mean
there's all these things that you know
why does every why why does every city
draw every young person from the
countryside right because of opportunity
and assignment possibility the
possibilities my friend Michael Mouse
was on the show yesterday and he was
telling me that he was choking he
swallowed a piece of food he got it
stuck in his throat and he went to a
table in Manhattan he was in Manhattan
and he was like I'm choking and he said
this to this table people and he said
this woman just stared at him with no
reaction like didn't smile anything and
he coughed and the food came up he goes
I was choking to death and she said well
you should take smaller bites like just
the harshness the harshness of New York
it's like the the the value of a human
being is so so much less because there's
so many of them yeah that's a problem in
the earth yeah right now our value for
and we become such a voyeur mmm we
become such voyeurs of like well I'll
just watch you die yeah I'll just I'll
get a video of it and put it you know
post this shoot stuff my hands I mean
instead of like wow that guy's needs
help he's hurting let's let me help him
right now it's like wow let's see you
know I mean we you see it's just it's a
strange phenomenon
you'll get more help when there's less
people around then you will when there's
all the people around yeah
they'll divvy thousand people no I'll
just sit there and stare at a guy that's
bleeding to death you know where when
there's two people there one of the
people will tourniquet the guy's leg
right right right like if you've met if
you saw someone in the woods fall and
break their leg and was just you two
you'd feel totally connected to that
person whereas if you saw someone 100
people around the guy falls or gets hit
by a car you like well I mean my problem
that ain't my problem yeah and everybody
goes that's not my problem just
everything you had a diffusion of
responsibility yeah it happens in large
groups of people feel like somebody's
gonna handle this semi and no one does
yeah no one does they yeah there was a
video that I watched recently of this
guy there was a I don't know what was
happening but it was outside at night
some sort of a nightclub sort of a
situation this woman hit this guy this
guy knocked out this one woman and then
another girl came out I mean knocked her
out too and the guys filming it
someone's filming it they're not doing
anything about it
no one's no one's tackling this guy no
one's grabbing the guy runs away
successfully and then the LAPD put a
thing out looking for this guy I'm like
how the [ __ ] does the guy with the
camera live with himself how did you
just eat elm exact I punched two women
exactly yeah exactly unless you're a
woman - and you're like I want this guy
[ __ ] me up - I don't know why you
just hit him with a brick then I mean
you know whatever I'm just saying just
you know ride your car you drive your
car on them I just would you know but
it's it is strange how we lose our
humanity and these we're doing it more -
now just with all of the there's a bunch
of factors that are playing in into into
that right into into us kind of
separating ourselves from the person
next door there right there but we're
we're over here you know we're on our
we're on our device looking down and
they're right next to us and we're lie
it's almost like we put we think that
that's an invisible screen